Hey everyone, it's Mike here from
Orflows and welcome back to my channel.
I'm glad you could join me for today's
video where I'm going to talk about the
age-old question, which is the best
chart that I should be using in my
market. And before I jump in again, you
know, if you've been enjoying these
videos, don't forget to subscribe to the
channel, click the notification bell so
you don't miss any new uploads. You
know, I'm trying to get at least one
video out a day, sometimes I get two.
Um, you know, I I my goal would be like
three ideally, but um
you know, I I'm always looking
towards the comment section because, you
know, it's it's fascinating.
Um, you know, some of the the feedback
that I get, you know, on and the
questions when seeing where traders
struggle and, you know, it's sort of
help clear that area up for you. So
you know, your support really goes a
long way in helping me create more
videos just like this one. All right, so
let's go ahead and get started with
today's topic because this came from a
user comment, um Michael.
I like your name, MichaelO5496.
He says, "Hey Mike, great video again.
What is the ideal chart for crude oil?
Um, parentheses tick, range, or
candlesticks? All the best." Now
the sadly there's no ideal chart for
anything.
Um
you know, trading is a personal journey.
There is an ideal chart for you, okay?
And
in deciding what type of chart is best
for you
you know, you have to understand um sort
of your your own trading mentality,
right? We all have a unique personality
traits, right? Some people are more
patient. Um, some people aren't, right?
Some people are are a bit more um
uh what's what's the word? Cardiac kids,
you know, in the sense that all, you
know, they need the the
the adrenaline um from a moving market
to think properly or something, you
know, it all depends. And also it comes
down to, you know, your account as well.
Can you
withstand bigger drawdowns or do you
want to try and keep the drawdowns as as
small as possible?
You know, are you an intraday trader
getting in and out of the market very
fast, just looking to pick up, you know,
a handful of ticks here or there, or are
you looking for more
grander moves? Okay, so
let's take a look. I'll I'll I'll sort
of go through how I would
determine, you know, what what chart
type. So, you know, the question was
specific to crude. Um tick range or
candlesticks. I think you meant
time-based. Um I always
use
you know, some form of candlestick.
Whether it's a footprint, right? I also
have a candlestick there. Um if if I was
looking at a regular time-based chart
like this,
um you know, I'd always start with a
candlestick. I'm not going to uh
you know, I mean, you do have a a choice
of charts that you can use. Obviously,
there's
you know, minute. You can use
Heikin-Ashi is something that I I like
to look at once in a while, maybe
sometimes when I'm when I'm bored.
You know, it's mainly the same. I mean,
the the the way Heikin-Ashi is is sort
of a blend of two candles into one, but
you sort of get the same you're going to
generally get the same movements.
Um
if uh
Whoops, here we go. Let's go here, back
to the sort of the different chart
types. Um you know,
they don't even have
simple bar chart here. But I don't get
involved with things like Kagi charts,
you know,
things like that. I mean, you can if you
want. Um you know, point and figure,
line break. Obviously, the volume
metric, which is a a form of a footprint
chart, is the NinjaTrader version.
But basically, I stick up here, right? I
stay within tick,
volume,
range,
second,
minute. Reason why second,
um
you know, when I'm I'm looking at a
second
based chart, I I
I use 30. I you know,
I don't think you can really go down to
at least me, um, you know, a 5-second
chart is going to be very fast. 15
seconds, okay, but then, you know, you
got to take into account things like
latency, okay? So, here we are. Let's
just go back to right now.
Um, this is a crude 1-minute chart.
This is where I believe you should
always start
in a market, right? Is a simple
time-based, you know, ideally 1-minute
chart. If you're an intraday trader,
people go, "Well, you know, I'm a
day-based trader." Okay, well, then
stick with the daily chart. But if
you're going to be scalping in and out,
looking for a quick moves here and
there,
um,
you know, you're going to want a
fast-moving chart. 1 minute is where I
would start as sort of my base, right?
In the sense of this is my starting
point, okay?
Can I understand what I'm seeing in the
order flow, right? Am I getting enough
movements in,
um, a bar? Okay, what I mean by enough
movements is, you know, is a are the
bars
basically having
up and down movements, um,
you know, the the vertical movements up
and down. And yeah, I mean, obviously
you're going to get big bars like this,
but really what I'm focusing in on is
the smaller bars, right? Okay, here's
three price levels on this bar right
here, 87.56, 57.58. That's at least sort
of the minimum that I'd be looking for,
okay? So, you know, 1-minute chart on
crude is, you know, sort of the minimum
that I would or, you know, I'm fine with
that. I'm comfortable. Uh, let's take a
look at 30 seconds, okay? And okay, 30
second,
you know,
when you're going to be running into the
sideways activity like this, you know,
you're going to see some bars here, two
price levels, two price levels.
Again, this is a 30-second chart.
So, it's moving, you know, you're
getting
decent movements on a 30-second chart.
So, yeah, I could probably
try and analyze a 30-second chart
because it's getting enough volume,
right? Bars are having, you know, a
couple couple hundred contracts, you
know, here. You do get some areas, some
pockets of illiquidity in the sense of
small volumes, 87, 83. Um
then it follows it up with, you know,
200, 400, back down to 100, 200, 97. So,
it's decent, okay? It It's about This is
about as low as I would go. I I, you
know, a 15-second chart I think is going
to be moving a bit too fast uh
for my taste, okay? I mean, yeah, on big
bars like this, okay, but realistically,
you know, you're going to be getting a
lot of bars like this where it's two
price levels, one price level, two price
levels. Obviously, during the more
busier times,
you know, you're going to get some
movements. Let's take a look starting at
8:00 a.m.
You know, basically, yeah, you're
getting some decent movements, but then
once it slows down,
it just flatlines on you, okay? And
again, you know, 15 seconds I think when
market's busy, may you start running
into some latency issues.
Um
then as far as tick-based charts, you
know, I I generally will start with 100.
What You know, when you're looking at a
tick-based chart, it's on, you know, the
amount of trades. I don't know why they
call it tick. I I guess so. I know why
they call it tick, but it make more
sense if they call it uh
Well, no, tick is fine. I I'd say trade,
but then people would think that's the
amount of trades. But, um
you know, the the way the markets are
nowadays,
with all these execution
algos, it's almost like
um
they break down the orders down to the
the smallest possible level. So, like
the average trade that goes through on
on a lot of markets, it's like a 1.4
contracts, just because it's, you know,
again, that's the average. Mostly, it
can't
It's just, you know, they they really
try to break it down and that's why
you're seeing, you know, this is a 100
tick chart. You know, the volume is 112,
1 107, 105, 125, 112, 150.
Um the ticks are really, you know, right
around there, okay?
You know, 100 tick chart is okay, decent
price movements. It looks a bit like a
uh
you know, 30-second chart, honestly, in
terms of movements. Now, obviously, when
there's going to be times where you get
some
you know, sort of a a rush of orders
coming in here and you you span a few
bars, right? 10:30:00,
14, 28. So, you got
within 30 seconds, you got three bars
forming.
Okay, so
you need sort of got to bear that in
mind. It can, you know, it's 10:30 and 9
seconds, 10:30 and 17 seconds. So,
within 8 seconds, you're forming another
bar. And then about 20 sec uh what is
that? 17 to 31, about 15 seconds,
another bar. 31 and 33 seconds to 31,
35, that's another
2 seconds and you got the next bar
forming.
Okay, so
it's just uh you know, you you can move
pretty fast on you um on crude at least
with a 100 tick. Now, what what are your
options? Well, you know,
you could try move up another level, you
know, 150 or 200 uh tick charts.
It's it's slowing it down a little bit,
okay? So, you can see like
you know, it's it's it's about close to
a 1-minute chart, honestly.
But really, at the end of the day, what
you want to be able to do is have a
chart where you can understand what's
happening in the order flow. It's not
about trying to go as low as you can go
um and as fast as you can go, but you
want to go as low and as fast as you can
go that's giving you information out of
the order flow that's actionable. Okay?
It's not about how fast you can trade. I
mean, something like this here is nice.
Coming up here to the high, you can just
sort of see the the buying getting
weakened.
Delta's getting, you know, 52 as you're
going up towards the high, the negative
then 42. Right up here at the high, just
five and then negative deltas coming in,
minus 41, minus 82, minus 72, the delta
volumes here. All right, strong negative
and you get a little bit of a sell-off.
Um
you know, that's on a 200 tick chart.
200 tick chart again, you're looking at
each bar is about 200 uh
contracts.
And if I was going to look at volume,
first I'd sort of go back to the
1-minute chart and sort of get an idea
of
you know, what's normal volume.
Obviously, you know, that 8:00 to 10:00
a.m. time is going to give you much more
volume on a minute-by-minute basis,
right? You can see some bars here, 900,
800, 400, 700. Um here's nothing, 170,
181. Um so, for volume, you know, you
you really got to sort of find your a
sweet spot. Um
100 I think is is too small.
Um that's just in my opinion, just way
too small.
Uh especially on a market that is, you
know, it's looking back at the busier
time.
Um you can just see nine Look at this
here, 9:01
in 4 seconds, 9 seconds.
And you're getting one bar, two bars,
three bars, four bars.
You're getting about four or five bars
within that 1 second. Okay, so that's
going to be hard to to trade. Um that's
a 100 volume.
Yeah,
you could add you can just hit
configure. Say you want to add a volume.
Um I do have 250 500 here, but if I
wanted to add, you know,
sometimes people like to use,
you know,
Fib numbers or whatever.
Um you can do that in here, right? You
would just add it to, you know,
whatever, I don't know, 987.
Okay.
Click apply. Click okay.
Honestly, between 987 and 1,000 there's
not going to be much different. But
then, you know, so I just sort of step
up,
you know, 500 volume.
Okay. Okay. It's decent cuz you really
want to focus, you know, when it's the
busy times of the day,
um is it something that's actionable,
right? And yeah, I mean 500 I think is
decent, but
you know, to at least from 8:00 to about
10:00 in the morning,
um you know, when the markets tend to
slow down, maybe
you can still keep it there, obviously,
cuz it's based on volume, but maybe it's
not getting,
you know, it's it's slowing down, right?
So, from, you know, here, 11:06,
the next bar takes about 5 minutes to
form, right? 11:06:52 to 11:11:06.
Right? But then there's some bars that's
very fast. 11:17:30,
11:17:37.
All right, that was that big bar on the
1-minute chart. So, you know, it it it
varies.
For me, I honestly I think a uh
a 1-minute chart is fine. Our
range-based charts,
um
usually I'll start with, you know, on
markets that have decent movements,
I'll usually use an eight-range chart,
you know, like currencies,
um
crude oil,
uh
S&P's, markets that have a little bit
more volatility, I would use something a
bit higher. Like if I was trading YM,
I'd probably use a 10-range or MNQ or
NQ, I'd probably go to a 15-range.
Cuz again, you know, at the end of the
day, you still want to just have a chart
that's going to put the order flow in a
format that's easy for you
to trade, to understand what you're
looking at. Okay?
And give you trades, basically. You
don't want to Again, if I were to go
down to a
four-range chart on crude oil,
okay? Let's just scroll back here to
sort of the busier
morning time.
Okay, what I see? I see a bunch of chop
back and forth here, right?
Red bar, green bar, red bar, green bar,
red bar, green bar.
Okay?
That's going to be difficult to trade.
I mean, you know, there's some more chop
here, and it's happening relatively
quick. How can I tell it's chop? Well,
red bar, red bar, green bar, green bar,
red bar, green bar, green bar, red bar,
green bar, green bar, red bar, red bar.
Just, you know, simple. So, you know, me
personally, I I
I would just rather use a chart, you
know, an eight-range, even, you know,
even a 10-range would probably be fine.
You know, and people say, "Don't hold me
say, 'Well, Mike says I got to use a
10-range.'" No, you can use a nine-range
if you want, if it makes sense to you.
Um
you know, but at least on a nine-range,
you know, using things like value areas
make sense to me.
All right? I've seen where there's
imbalances, cuz I'm getting enough
volume taking place in a bar
that
it's easy for me to understand what I'm
seeing in the order flow, okay?
So, at the end of the day, there's no
right chart. There's a right chart for
you and your trading style. Again, I
know guys
that
use a three-range chart
on crude. I can't. That's But that's me.
They can. They're they're fine with how
quick it can move. I mean, if you
remember this morning,
right? Here, you mean,
it's moved 900 24 seconds,
you know, within
30 seconds, you've got
move from,
you know, 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 bars, basically.
But, again, it it it depends on your
trading style.
What chart what type of chart you want
to use, okay? So, again, it's a personal
journey.
Cuz I did see in another comment, oh,
these uh you know, someone else, not
you, uh Michael, someone else had
mentioned that they were advised to use
a five range chart on I forgot what
market it was. I think it was crude,
also, or something.
And the guy he's saying that he's
struggling.
Well, it's your chart. What works for
one person
doesn't always work for some somebody
else, right? And just like sports,
right? Sports and trading have a lot of
overlapping.
Okay? I have got
two boys. They both play soccer. One's a
goalie. The other one
is new position now. Even before he was
right wing. Now now they they they want
to play
uh midfielder.
And
he doesn't want to play goalie.
Okay? It's a different skill set, right?
He he's got speed, so he can come back
and defend, and he can also attack.
Whereas, my son plays goalie, he likes
to sort of lay back,
survey the market, so to speak, you
know, survey what's going on on the
pitch.
Okay? And so, it's the same thing. I
mean, they're both good,
but they're good in their own ways.
And it's the same
in the markets, right? You got to find
what
way that you can analyze the market
that's going to make the market make
sense to you, so that you can succeed.
Okay?
So,
I I hope that answers your question.
Um
sort of how I go through sort of the
process of finding
what chart I could use. And to be
honest, it's not like I have a lot of
different chart types that I use. Like,
for this market, you know, for crude,
I'm going to use eight range chart, but
this other market, I'm going to use
12 range chart, and another market, I'm
going to use a seven range chart. No,
generally, I honestly I I generally keep
it at four range charts for markets that
move uh
slower, like bonds.
Um
Just normal markets, like crude oil,
S&P's, I'll use an eight range chart,
currencies. Um
Most of the grains, I'll use a four
range chart.
Markets that move a bit faster, like uh
NQ,
I'll use a 15 range chart. YM, you know,
I can use an eight range chart on YM,
but I actually use a 10 range chart. I
think it's fine.
Uh if
if I've noticed the volatility's picking
up, then I'll go to a 15 range chart.
But generally, you know, it's 4, 8,
and
you know, 15. And it's just 15 for those
more vol, you know, for NQ specifically.
So, basically, 4 and 8. So, it's not
like I'm using, you know, this market is
a three range chart, this one's an
eight. Cuz I I see guys post stuff up.
And it's like every time they put Oh,
yeah, this big winner. Then I look at
their chart, cuz, you know, they're
posting every day. They always like to
show their charts, you know, and and
um
one day it's a 1,000 range chart, the
next day it's a 1987 chart, the next day
it's it's a three-minute chart.
Well,
you know, that doesn't make sense to me,
right? You really got to choose your
chart,
stick with it.
If it's not working for you, then you
can adjust it, okay?
But you don't just adjust it on the fly.
You want to make it a chart
that you can understand what's taking
place in the markets, okay? So, anyway,
guys, I'll end that video here for
today. Again, again, I hope that clears
that up on on what sort of charts
my my sort of my process of going
through
the charts. So,
if you find this uh helpful, be sure to
leave a comment below, you know, because
at the end of the day you under you
know, order flow is is very robust,
right? And you want to have enough
trades taking place in a bar
that makes that has it makes sense.
Okay?
So, if you enjoyed this video and you're
having already, be sure to subscribe to
the channel so you don't miss any new
videos that are coming out.
So, thanks so much for watching and
being a part of my order flow community
and I'll catch you guys on the next
video. Bye-bye.